we focused on this now because it's been
a decade since the global recession of
2008-2009 and some interesting and and
wearing vulnerabilities are also popping
up at the moment in 2008 in 2009 the
dominoes were really set up for quite a
steep on Anne Shiell and economic crisis
this time the economic vulnerabilities
aren't quite as large they're large
enough that we could see a slowdown in
GDP growth the slowdown in trade and
things of that nature the real risk is
that our lack of preparedness and the
the lack of room for global cooperation
will turn what starts as kind of a minor
downturn into something much larger and
much more difficult to deal with
sometime the next year or two
the last big global downturn began in
the United States with the collapse of
the housing bubble in the financial
sector there next time the trouble is
much more likely to start elsewhere and
perhaps in the emerging world emerging
economies are a much larger share of
global output than they used to be
they've also gone on something of a
borrowing binge over the last ten years
which means that they could be due for a
reckoning there are also reasons to be
concerned about the euro area and in
particular Italy which has an enormous
public debt problem and where markets
have been feeling a bit jittery about
their ability to pay that back and that
could relaunch the euro area debt crisis
that we saw about a half decade ago the
tools government's normally used to
fight a recession won't be available in
the same way that they normally are the
next time around interest rates will be
very low and so we normally rely on
central banks to do interest rate
cutting to perk up spending break up
growth and they're not going to be able
to do that so pretty quickly they're
gonna have to turn to less tested
methods money printing to buy bonds
quantitative easing was something that
was used last time that's going to be
used again but that works in a much more
uncertain way and is much more
politically contentious than some of the
tools that are ordinarily used within
countries the problem is that government
is much more polarized across the world
you have many more populist parties
nationalist parties and it's going to be
very hard to reach the agreement that's
necessary to launch big spinning
programs and
of that nature then you also have
disagreements across countries which
means that it's much more likely you
have contentious policies tariffs that
go up currency wars things of that
nature as countries struggle to deal
with the next downturn ideally
governments would be taking some steps
right now to get ready for the next
recession they should be changing their
central bank policy targets what we've
learned is that a low inflation target
doesn't give central bank's enough room
to fight recessions before interest
rates fall to zero they should also be
getting their budgets ready which means
preparing to include measures that will
increase spending automatically when the
economy weakens in the future so that
they don't have to have to have fights
in Parliament about whether or not to
expand spending when the time comes but
then most important of all I think
governments need to coordinate their
responses with each other that makes it
much more likely that we don't enter a
scenario like we did in the 1930s when
tariff barriers went up when there were
currency wars and competitive
devaluations and when ultimately that
led to some pretty significant and nasty
geopolitical tension